showing up to protect businesses did you
interact with any of these people
oh yeah yeah i was live streaming with
them and they um we're just telling
people this is not what this is not the
target
you're not why are you targeting private
businesses like what are you what are
you doing a lot of businesses say family
owned hey it's already been so hard
on on the business it's already been
hard on the community here because of
already what's been going on
from covid and so then they put these um
i'm on i'm on live right right now
no shut up shut up oh
why are we going private yeah why you
going private why are you burning down
small
businesses yeah yeah right here can you
hear me yeah they can hear you go ahead
tell them why you're white guys burning
these down
we're not trying to burn down small
businesses you're just in the way
oh yeah right here they sell lemons
they don't give a [ __ ] about who got
money or who's doing what so they sell
bad cars that's why you guys burn them
down that's not even that you're in the
way
do you have a source for that mr clown
knows punk ass [ __ ]
there's not a big population of black
folks here okay
so therefore for you to target a black
man that has children
in his car and harm him while he's
trying to de-escalate the situation
elijah can you let me speak with him can
you give me can you give him your
headphone do you mind here
can i can i yeah can you put when he's
in here can you talk to him online on
camera
you could see this here this year here
all right let's grab this i apologize if
elijah doesn't get his
can you hear me sir no go ahead i can
hear you right now
okay so what's your name sir i can't
tell you my name
oh okay anonymous and what have you i
understand so um
i won't say anonymous because that's a
different corporation what i would say
is i'm a concerned black
man yeah you're a concerned black man so
you think that it's justified to burn
down a private car lot do you have any
evidence any source if they sell lemons
there buddy
i was just here in december trying to
buy a car okay so you bought the car and
it didn't work
on the street i didn't buy the car why i
was down the street
ah because the cars don't start
but we're not talking about this lot
we're not trying to make it about
businesses but you burn down the
business sir so it matters
i didn't burn down the business okay
well can you can you denounce then
and condemn people who burn down the
business i will not denounce
nobody i'm a concern
black man yeah i'm a concerned white i'm
a concerned
american citizen and i happen to be
white but we do have a black man here in
studio
uh because you're burning down a lot of
black businesses like you know
for years it was like i have a black
friend but i have
a white friend that i grew up with and i
love dearly
they have my back that i have no doubt
have my back
but
but are you not concerned with
businesses being burned down and you and
your
your group there destroying the own your
own city that you have to live in that
doesn't concern you
that's a little bit different from
actually burning down someone's business
but you just mentioned i'd like to know
you just mentioned a man jacob flake
jacob flake talking about this we
haven't concerned
black white american latino
everybody that's going to work just to
make a living
to make sure that they occupy for their
family
okay that's burned down too because we
have to get
10 percent check before we go in how do
you know you're not
where do you work but it's not
concerning you where do you work
yeah in america mm-hmm what do you do
you make a living yeah how do you make a
living how do you contribute
we're going to work with [ __ ] in yeah
you can't tell us at all about what you
do how do you contribute to american
society aside from not condemning people
who burn down parking lots
i like the tribute i don't burn down
parking lots
oh well there you go i guess we've
lowered the standard there a little bit
but i appreciate it
man we do have to get going but i
appreciate it uh you taking the time man
i disagree with you
but uh hopefully you'll be friendly with
our guy here this is
his name his name is stephen crowder
steven crowder steven crowder yeah
steven frog yes sir let me say to you
yeah go ahead
have you ever been to kenosha wisconsin
i actually have family who live in
wisconsin yeah i've driven through there
a couple of times
no no i'll say have you been to kenosha
wisconsin
ah no i don't live in kenosha wisconsin
here we go trump card have you been
we're not talking
i've driven i've been to kenosha
wisconsin yes
where have you been 52nd street
let's get to the point i've been to
kenosha you're obviously a local go
ahead
the problem is it wasn't a problem until
it became a problem
yeah it wasn't a problem until you guys
started burning down [ __ ] you're right
okay guess what
thank you all right your neighbors could
be next yeah it really actually was give
it a whirl buddy they did it
give it a whirl hey burn down you have
my info
can i get that sorry all right thanks
thanks for being on the show thank you
very much he was in dallas earning a
living thank you
uh yes yeah thank you for being so like
political yes i don't know if you're
what i'm saying it's not about that but
at the end of the day why are you at
this parking lot
because they don't give a damn well i
i'm just because someone burned down a
parking lot
and it's private property i'm here
they're taking the whole corpse of
the negativity no no they brought all
the negativity
kenosha is a giant suck of negativity
that negativity though man come on i
guess i would have i guess i would see
it differently if i was on 52nd street
yeah lacrosse 52nd connection
we're trying to
yeah well you know what i'm glad that he
i'm glad that he put some of the
negative stereotypes
of the activists in kenosha wisconsin to
rest
thanks thanks i love thanks for putting
my life
and my safety i'm sorry steven loves his
gut so much
just put their lives on the line for
your entertainment thank you steven i
apologize i did i got carried away but
you know i've been out there myself
and i just the guy
i'll tell you what i'll send you a
sherry's berries oh
there you go that's sweet it's very
thoughtful i'm sorry i do apologize
somewhere else i know i just i can't
help myself i get so
oh well you're not undercover yeah
anyways patriotic people know
unless you're wearing something that
says death to america
gosh yeah that guy there really seems my
country he really seems entitled uh
and uh i don't think that man works
hey look my shirt just changed colors
how did that happen
well it's the same way that i can make
the magic
of the walrus
it's the magic of tv we can cut it and
then you're not watching this live but
hey there are videos playing in boxes
you can click one of those if you want
to watch more subscribe hit the
notification bell for all notifications
new videos
every day eight eastern nine eastern i
don't know it's one of those
and um hit like comment you don't have
to
wait where'd the cup go